nope instead they get it to hayward  and gordon is fouled by brogdon but  because  of that being the first file in the  final two minutes  you have to do it again four years i'm  glad lamela didn't try that that'd been  laura  zealous for rookie to throw it off yeah  yeah i'm going to run the play the coach  designed coming out of that huddle  again sabonis is showing his backs up  there you go he did it into the horn of  twins the laser in 1.6 one for you and  one for me  and the hornets win on a friday night  all right hornets needed it  they had a lead of a 14 at one point  they lit by 11 in the third quarter and  then they gave it all up  they gave it up and we're down 10 100 to  98  at the 306 mark of our fourth quarter  but dell curry they close on a 10-5